[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Barbara halweg guten Abend schön dass
Sie dabei sind wie auch Norbert Lehmann
für den Sport ein schön guten Abend auch
von mir es gibt eine Einigung im
Tarifstreit im öffentlichen Dienst die
Beschäftigten der Länder bekommen mehr
Geld außerdem haben wir diese Themen für
Sie Ziele in Gefahr die
erdölpoduzierenden Länder wollen den
Ausstieg aus fossilen Energien auf dem
Gipfel in Dubai
verhindern keinen Abbau des sozial
rüendeckung für den Kanzler beim SPD
Parteitag wird Olaf Scholz bejubelt und
erteilt dem Abbau des Sozialstaats eine
Absage wichtiger Schutz oder
technologiebremse erstmals einigt sich
die EU auf Regeln für den Umgang mit
künstlicher
Intelligenz
vier Tage vor dem Ende der
Weltklimakonferenz in Dubai löste heute
ein Brief der OPEC Wut und Entrüstung
aus die Organisation Erdöl förördernder
Länder ruft ihre Mitglieder dazu auf
jegliche Beschlüsse gegen fossile
Energien zu blockieren genau das aber
ist eine der brennendsten Fragen der
Konferenz ob es gelingt sich auf einen
Ausstieg aus Kohle Öl und Gas zu einigen
um die Erderwärmung zu begrenzen Elisa
mibach und andre
stammberichten and fossil fuels raus aus
Kohle Öl und Gas es ist der größte
Protestzug bisher auf der Klimakonferenz
sie fordern es seit Jahren jetzt ist es
im Munde der Entscheider ein großer Teil
der Weltgemeinschaft will Ernst machen
mit dem Ausstieg diese Aussicht erzeugt
Panik das Ölkartell OPEC fordert alle
Mitglieder zum Veto auf Unmut bei der
Außenministerin die federführen für die
EU
verhandelt das ist nach wie vor ein
dickes Brett
weil es immer noch diejenigen gibt die
ihre Machtpolitik aus der Vergangenheit
auch in die Zukunft führen wollen auch
mit machtpolitischen fossilen
Instrumenten drahtsilakt für die
Vereinigten Arabischen Emirate die
Gastgeber wollen einen klimaerfolg
vorweisen aber gleichzeitig Öl und Gas
ausbauen ihre Idee die Emissionen
einfach schön rechnen sie sind dabei
landzachten im großen Stil z.B ein
Fünftel der Fläche von simbabweö als
Bayern zum Bäume pflanzen der Dorfchef
von niam hunga er wurde nicht gefragt in
unserer heutigen Sitzung hörte ich zum
ersten Mal dass Menschen im Bezirk für
das Pflanzen von Bäumen bezahlt werden
sie bekommen 20 pro
Monat nicht nur in Simbabwe in
mindestens fünf Ländern weltweit
Verträge für riesige Flächen damit das
Ölgeschäft in Dubai weiterlaufen kann
ein Täuschungsmanöver so Experten denn
so viele Bäume könne man gar nicht
Pflanzen ja oft man hat man den Eindruck
dass die ölproduzierenden Länder so das
Leben der fossilen Energien verlängern
wollen durch verschiedene Aktivitäten
und es scheint davon abzulenken dass man
ja eigentlich wirklich aussteigen muss
aus fossilen Energien die
Weltgemeinschaft ist so nah dran wie nie
einen Ausstieg zu beschließen die Frage
ist ob es ein echter wird keine falschen
Lösungen warnen nicht nur die
Demonstrierenden nach Deutschland sichts
fehlender Milliarden will die SPD die
Schuldenbremse auch
2024 aussetzen das beschlossen die
Delegierten zumindest indirekt auf dem
Bundesparteitag in Berlin
Koalitionspartner FDP lehnt das
allerdings strickt ab mit Spannung wurde
der Auftritt des Bundeskanzlers erwartet
der bekam viel Applaus und wurde vom
ususo Chef dazu aufgefordert den gelben
die rote Karte zu zeigen Brita
spiermann die Erwartungen der
Delegierten an ihn sind groß schlechte
Umfragewerte Haushaltskrise die Partei
will Antworten und Olaf Scholz gibt eine
Garantie für mich ist ganz klar es wird
in einer solchen Situation keinen Abbau
des Sozialstaats in Deutschland geben wo
sonst gespart werden könnte lässt er
offen bei der Unterstützung für die
Ukraine auf jeden Fall nicht das macht
Scholz klar wir müssen solidarisch der
Ukraine helfen könen er spricht auch
Solidarität und über außerordentliche
Krisen Scholz appelliert an die
Geschlossenheit der SPD seine Rede kommt
an mit Abstrichen ich würde mir aber
wünschen dass er auch als Kanzler öfter
mal den Macher herausstellt der
Parteitag sendet Signale Reform der
Einkommens und der Erbschaftssteuer eine
krisenabgabe für Reiche und ein
Aussetzen der Schuldenbremse für
204 das aber ist mit der FDP nicht zu
machen selbstkritisch ist Scholz nicht
aberig
manches von dem was da so passiert ist
hätte ich echt nicht gebraucht kräftiger
Gegenwind kommt nur von den jusus der
Jugendorganisation der SPD der
Vertrauensverlust der Menschen in die
Partei und in den Kanzler sei groß da
draußen brennt die Hütte wir können hier
drinnen in der Halle nicht einfach auf
heile Welt tun zu Gast ist der spanische
Ministerpräsident Sanchez gemeinsam
versteht man sich als Bollwerk gegen
Rechtspopulisten der Parteitag liefert
viel Applaus für Scholz fürs erste
scheint die Partei versöhnt und gibt dem
Kanzler Rückendeckung für die Beratungen
über die Haushaltskrise die rote Linie
Kürzungen im
Sozialbereich fragen wir Matthias farnof
in Berlin wie konnte der Kanzler Punkten
und was heißt das fürs weitere
regieren na ja es war reichlich Druck im
Kessel aber Olaf Scholz hat es geschafft
Ruhe und zu icht auszustrahlen gemeinsam
sind wir stark das war sein Tenor
Sozialabbau nicht mit uns das kam gut an
bei den 600 Delegierten die Konturen der
klassischen Sozialdemokratie waren da
sichtbar aber so harmonisch konnte das
nur ablaufen weil der Elefant im Raum
weitgehend ignoriert wurde das 17
Milliarden Loch im Haushalt
2024 das werde man schon in den Griff
kriegen nur wie auf die Wohlfühlmomente
heute folgt schon morgen der nächste
koalitionspoker wie man sich da einigen
kann ist in der Parteitagsrede des
Kanzlers offen geblieben vielen Dank für
diese Einschätzung aus Berlin Matthias
vnof war das vom Bundesparteitag der SPD
nach wochenlangen Warnstreiks gibt es im
Tarifstreit des öffentlichen Dienstes
der Länder eine Einigung die mehr als
eine Million Beschäftigten bekommen
schrittweise über 25 Monate mehr Geld
nach Gewerkschaftsrechnung
durchschnittlich gut 11% für sie zählt
dass der Abschluss mit dem von Bund und
Kommunen mithält die Arbeitgeber
sprechen von einem
herausfordernden aber Machbaren Ergebnis
Nicola Albrecht hat
Details man sieht ihn die Erleichterung
an nach nächtelangem verhandeln doch
noch einen Tarifabschluss erreicht zu
haben ein Erfolg findet werd Chef Frank
we alle Beschäftigten des öffentlichen
Dienstes sind gleichermaßen von hohen
Preisen betroffen und wir haben einen
grassierenden Arbeitskräftemangel in
allen Bereichen des öffentlichen
Dienstes und wir haben jetzt ein
Verhandlungsergebnis das wertig ist die
Arbeitgeberseite nennt es angesichtsk
klammerkassen ein teures Geschenk zum
zweiten
Advent für uns ging es immer darum
einerseits einen fairen Abschluss für
die Beschäftigten zu erreichen aber eben
auch einen machbaren Abschluss für die
Länderhaushalte und so sieht der
Abschluss für die insgesamt 1,1
Millionen Beschäftigten aus zum
Ausgleich der Inflation erhalten Sie
steuerfreie Sonderzahlungen von
insgesamt 3000 € ab November 2024 gibt
es dann 200 € mehr Lohn und ab Februar
2025 soll der Lohn dann um 5,5% steigen
die Laufzeit beträgt 25 Monate durchaus
akzeptabel meinen einige der Betroffenen
die Zeiten sind nicht so gut das haben
alle mitbekommen warum soll man Landes
Beschäftigte schlechter behandeln als
als Beschäftigte im Bund das hat der
Arbeitgeber gesehen das finden das
finden wir gut wird der Abschluss wie
üblich auf die Beamtinnen und Beamten
übertragen bekommen mehr als dre
Millionen Beschäftigte mehr
Geld zum Krieg in narost da ist eine
UN-Resolution zu einem sofortigen
Waffenstillstand im Gazastreifen
gescheitert am Veto der USA scharfe
Kritik kommt von
Hilfsorganisationen man sei entsetzt
angesichts der humanitären Lage laut
welternährungs Programm steht die
Versorgung der Palästinenser vor dem
Kollaps weil nur ein Bruchteil der
benötigten Hilfsgüter ankomme mehr als
eine Million Menschen hungere so die
Organisation die israelische Armee
bombardierte erneut Städte im
Gazastreifen die Hamas ihrerseits
feuerte Raketen auf Israel
ab die EU hat sich auf ein wie sie sagt
weltweit einmaliges Gesetz geeinigt es
soll einer bedeutenden
Zukunftstechnologie Regeln geben der
künstlichen Intelligenz kurz ki ki
beruht auf selbstlernenden sozusagen
selbstdenkenden Computerprogrammen im
Einsatz etwa bei der automatischen
Gesichtserkennung außerdem kann die KI
Texte Bilder gar Filme erstellen sie
wertet riesige Datenmengen aus etwa aus
dem Internet und trifft teils schon
eigenständig Entscheidungen das birgt
Chancen aber auch Gefahren Florian
Neuhann um kurz vor Mitternacht gibt es
in Brüssel erleichterten Applaus und
wenig später einen EU-Kommissar voller
Stolz fast drei Tage haben wir zum
Schluss verhandelt ich habe nur ein Wort
historisch als erste Region weltweit
will Europa KI regulieren ob Chatbots
oder Programme die längst in vielen
Bereichen eingesetzt werden Aki
entscheidet ob ich einen Job bekomme ob
ich ein dalin bekomme ob ich zu Uni
gehen darf das heißt wenn dieser
Algorithmen lebenswichtigen
Entscheidungen treffen dann wird es Zeit
dass wir sie auch ordentlich regulieren
was Europa jetzt versucht das Gesetz
sieht unter anderem vor die
Kennzeichnung von KI Inhalten bei
besonders risikoreichen Anwendungen die
letzte Kontrolle durch Menschen verboten
wird unter anderem massenhaftes Auslesen
von gesichtsbildern aus dem Netz die
echtzeitiidentifizierung von Menschen in
öffentlichen Räumen soll nur in
Ausnahmefällen erlaubt werden wenn es
einen bestimmten Verdächtigen gibt und
auch einen Beschluss seitens des
Gerichts ist es möglich nach dieser
Person zu fanden und ja dann auch mit
Mitteln einer Erkennung aber das ist
kein Abgleich von allen Menschen auf der
Straße mit großen Datenbanken wie man
sich vorstellt wie es in China gemacht
wird die Branche selbst fürchtet dass
Europa abgehängt wird die EU muss die
gleiche Energie und die Aktivitäten die
sie für die Regulierung investiert haben
aber auch in Investition und Förderung
von europäischen ki-prukten setzen wir
dürfen technologisch nicht weiter von
China und den USA abhängig machen lassen
übrigens wen die künstliche Intelligenz
von Chat GPT fragt was von der Einigung
zu halten sei erhält diese Antwort das
ist sicherlich ein bedeutender
Schritt was sollten wir über künstliche
Intelligenz wissen was gehört alles zur
KI die wesentlichen Punkte haben wir für
Sie herausgearbeitet und die finden Sie
jederzeit online bei ZDF heute und in
unserer App nach Frank ich wegen ihrer
Verwicklung in den islamistisch
motivierten Mord am Lehrer Samuel pati
sind fünf Schüler zu Bewährungsstrafen
verurteilt worden ein weiterer muss sech
Monate in Haft vor gut zwei Jahren war
Partie von einem 18-jährigen getötet und
dann enthauptet worden bei der
Vorbereitung hatten die Schüler geholfen
die Polizei erschoss den Täter vor dem
Mord war gegen den Lehrer gehetzt worden
weil er angeblich den Propheten Mohammed
beleidigt
hatte g harter Schnitt jetzt zu diesen
vier grazchen von der Messe ComicCon in
Stuttgart für Außenstehende mag das
möglicherweise ein wenig skuril anmuten
wenn sich Menschen mit großer
Begeisterung in ihre Comic oder
Serienhelden verwandeln und dann zur
Messe pilgern aber wer den Bericht von
Jasmin astaki Barde sieht der ahnt das
kann ein ziemlicher Spaß sein ein
schillerndes Spektakel was sich hier dem
Auge bietet ob nun Star Wars Krieger
oder Mario Helden auf der ComicCon
Deutschlands größter comicmesse werden
sie leibhaftig da ich auf Comic so stehe
mag ich halt echt Comic charakterie zu
sehen das ist genau mein Ding also h
gibt echt krasse Cosplayer muss ich
sagen wegen so welchen Leuten wegen so
welchen Outfits genau wegen SAS ich
hergekommen man fühlt sich zu Hause man
fühlt sich einfach du weißt genau die
Leute verurteilen dich nicht weil du so
bist die Leute machen sich nicht lustig
über dich viele der BesucherInnen sind
sogenannte Costum Player das heißt sie
Schüpfen in die Rolle ihr Superhelden
die Idee entstand in den 80er Jahren in
Japan auch in Deutschland gibt es längst
eine große Fangemeinde hier kann sich
jeder ausleben vom fünfjährigen der noch
im Kinderwagen sitzt der als xwing
gestylt ist bis zum 70 80-jährigen der
halt auf die alten Serien oder
irgendwelche superhero Geschichten steht
vieles was hier sehr futuristisch
anmutet sehen Soziologen als uraltes
Phänomen seit ersten Bildgeschichten auf
Papyrus Sache die die Menschheit sicher
immer ausgezeichnet hat und vielleicht
weiterhin auszeichnen wird ist dass sie
nach Geschichten hungert und sie gute
Geschichten liebt und im besten Fall
sind Comics gute Geschichten oder Welten
die dadurch erschaffen werden für die
Comic Fans ist das ein Wochenende voller
Freiheit und Spaß indem sie ihre Träume
und Fantasien
ausleben in den 70er Jahren zählte er zu
den erfolgreichsten Hollywood Stars
jetzt ist Ryan o mit 0 Jahren gestorben
den Durchbruch feierte oil mit love
story dem Drama um eine Liebe die
stärker ist als Krankheit und Tod für so
viel Gefühl bekam er mit Filmpartnerin
McGraw später einen Stern auf dem Walk
of Fame tragig komisch konnte oil aber
auch etwa in dem Road Movie paper Moon
von
1973 Jubel bei den Skispringern da gab's
heute in klingental endlich den ersten
deutschen saisonseg jawohl ja und vor
allem dank der Topleistung von Karl
Geiger der 30jährige gewann in
klingental ganz knapp vor dem
Österreicher Stefan Kraft und dem
Japaner rioyo Kobayashi übrigens der
erste deutsche Weltcup Einzelsieg
überhaupt auf der sächsischen
schanceze Karl Geiger vollkommen außer
sich vor Freude denn sein Triumph fürs
dsvteam auch der erste Saisonsieg
überhaupt Geiger führender nach dem
ersten Durchgang landet im zweiten
nervenstark bei 146 m dann ist ein grimi
Geiger hdün vor Kraft und kobashi nicht
erwartet es waren jetzt wirklich mit
Abstand die zwei besten Sprünge hier im
weckkampf und ja Wahnsinn auch wie weit
heute gesprungen worden ist mit guter
Landung nach dem Springen war dann
feiern angesagt im Nebel von
klingental erfolgreicher weltcupst der
Deutschen rennrotlerinnen in Lake PLD
heute Julia Taube zweite gestern ebenso
daniana eidberger und sask Schirmer im
Doppelsitzer ja und Team Kollege Max
Langenhahn der setzte seine Siegesserie
der vergangenen Saison fort und gewann
im Einsitzer der siebte Erfolg in Folge
für den
Vizeweltmeister und beim Weltcup in
laplan hier verpasst Johannes Lochner im
zwebob nur knapp den Sieg als führender
nach dem ersten Lauf beginnt Lochner den
zweiten Lauf direkt mit einem Fehler
kommt dann aber hinten raus doch noch
auf 7h an den Sieger Michael Vogt aus
der Schweiz heran Dritter wird Francesco
Friedrich zur Fußballbundesliga ja und
da hat die Eintracht den deutschen
Meister regelrecht zerlegt hier die
bisherigen Ergebnisse des 14 Spieltags
Frankfurt besinkt München mit 5:1 Union
gewinnt gegen gladback 3:1 erster Sieg
nach 16 Pflichtspielen Wolfsburg
unterliegt Freiburg 0:1 Bremen Augsburg
2:0 Heidenheim Dannstadt 3:2 das
abendpiel Dortmund gegen Leipzig und
bereits gestern besiegte Hoffenheim den
VfL Bochum mit 3:1 morgen das Duell der
Spitzen Stuttgart gegen Leverkusen und
danach das Duell der Kellerkinder Köln
gegen maiz die Tabelle oben alles
unverändert Leverkusen Spitzenreiter von
münchenstuttgart drit vor Leibzig
Dortmund und Hoffenheim die zweite
Tabellenhälfte beginnt mit bladbach ja
und am Tabellenende hat Union zunächst
die Abstiegsplätze verlassen dahinter
Köln Darmstadt und
Mainz das Abendspiel BVB gegen RB
ausfühlich bei uns zu sehen im Aktuellen
Sportstudio 23:30 Uhr zu Gast Bayern
Mittelfeld Star und Nationalspieler Leon
getzka Trauer um die deutsche ruderikone
Peter Michael Kolbe seine fünf
Weltmeistertitel im einer sind bis heute
Rekord bei Olympia verpasste er dreimal
die Goldmedaille hier letztmals 1988 in
Soul im deutschdeutschen Duell gegen
Thomas Lange aus der DDR Kolbe wde 70
Jahre
alt das war's V Sport danke schönt der
zweite Advent wird regnerisch windig und
mild wo sich auch mal die Sonne zeigt
erzählt gleich Katja horneffer :15 Uhr
meldet sich Anne gellineck mit dem heute
journal wir wünschen Ihnen noch einen
angenehmen Abend bis morgen wenn Sie
mögen auf
[Musik]
Wiedersehen
guten Abend mit tiefwanja wird es heute
Nacht stürmisch über den britischen
Inseln und dem Ärmelkanal bei uns in
Deutschland beschränken sich diese
kräftigen Windböhen auf die westlichen
mittelgeberger tiefwanja und seine
Nachfolger bringen aber viel Regen mit
innerhalb von 5 Tagen können z.B rund um
den Schwarzwald um die 100 lit Regen pro
Quadratmeter fallen zusammen mit der
Schneeschmelze in den Alpen werden die
Wasser Stände von kleineren Bächen und
Flüssen aber durchaus auch von Donau und
Rhein ansteigen schon heute nachregend
ist kräftig und hier im Südosten ist
vielleicht auch noch etwas Schnee dabei
da kannst dann für Glätte reichen denn
dort sinken die Temperaturen bis -2°
sonst bleibt die Nacht bei 7 bis 2° zu
meist milder morgen liegen die
Höchsttemperaturen an der Ostsee bei 4°
am Main und am Rhein werden 11° erreicht
und vor allen Dingen über
Norddeutschland ziehen morgen viele
Regenwolken hinweg vielleicht zeigt sich
anfänglich rund um Dresden noch mal kurz
die Sonne sp dann auch mal im Sauerland
freundlicher sieht's aus westlich des
Rheins und im Südwesten bei einem recht
kräftigen Wind aus südwestlichen
Richtungen windig mild und regnerisch
geht es in den nächsten Tagen weiter am
Mittwoch könnte es im Nordosten schon
wieder für nasse Schneeflocken reichen
guten
Abend